ils étaient plusieurs centaines de
marseillais tous rassemblés là où le
petit nicolas a disparu il ya maintenant
16 mois
comme si chacun ici pouvait se sentir
concerné par le drame de michel bourgat
qui a vu disparaître son fils d'un coup
de couteau
il est devenu le symbole nollet
conciliation il est pas cette image
politiques et sociaux devenus les
symboles de la ville
sincère de france de la vie le carbone
rue nicolas bordas ce pourrait être
aussi rue de la violence urbaine
depuis ce meurtre michel bourgat n'a
cessé de multiplier les rencontres les
initiatives pour tenter de sensibiliser
les hommes politiques
je commence à voir enfin nos hommes
politiques dire en fait les mêmes choses
que moi j'ai dit il ya 15 mois c'est à
dire qu'il faut qu'on traite les
délinquants multirécidivistes qui faut
qu on traite autrement la délinquance
juvénile que par des lois angélique loi
angélique juge d'enfants trop laxiste
justice en manque de moyens monsieur
bourgoin n'a jamais caché qu'il se
battrait toute sa vie pour celui qui l'a
perdu trop brutalement
c'est un local en rez-de-chaussée au
quartier de la farouette tout à la fois
vestiaire pour le club de foot cantine
pendant le ramadan une salle ouverte le
soir depuis un an pour ces jeunes en
majorité au chômage des jeunes c'est un
fait mais réalité d'horizon mais si
c'est pour être l'un des blocs et des
porsche et sa grange et parce qu'ils
sont là il n'ya parfois autant mieux
qu'ils aient un local et isère et gens
qui puissent les encadrer et leur donner
les moyens et les outils et bottes de
passer de bonnes soirées qui est entre 2
1 parce que l'horizon la maison le
quartier l'union sportive de bagatelle
et celle de farouette sont les trois
lieux de rencontres possibles le soin
russie pas de mr and mrs
djilali l'animateur tient à nous
présenter celui dans le groupe est le
plus fier khadr il a créé une entreprise
de coursiers avec quatre copains
respecté ici il ne trouve que peu d'
excuses aux tout jeunes casseurs ne
s'est pas à 15 seulement ça rien de
grave et des voitures parce qu'il parte
attaqué faisant rentrer à la maison à
10h aura le football aux spams ont su
quelque chose mais je vais me passer
pour lui dire je suis passé par là
je peux confirmer que à l'âge de 15 ans
pour ça il faut on sait ce qu il faut on
croise un peu l'avenir
à la même heure non loin de là la
brigade anticriminalité patron ces
policiers ont plus de dix ans de service
jouer aux gendarmes et aux voleurs ils
connaissent mes ennemis ne rompez
distille changer les règles de l'art il
ya quinze jours la porte de ce milliard
défoncée à la voiture bélier c'est une
semaine qu'ils ont envers nous c'est
tout c'est de la haine et au travers de
rouen n'en sais rien parce que nous on
n'a pas changé elle est toujours
policier on est toujours en a que je
veux courir après les voleurs voilà
mais à l'avancé explique que moi je ne
sais pas ce que vous avez l'impression
parfois de les harceler et recelé non
pourquoi parce qu'on passe dans les
quartiers difficiles où mais on sait
ainsi qu'à des voitures qui concerne on
sait qu'on va lever une voiture volée on
sait que bon on passe dans ces quartiers
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de deux parce
que ça bouge ce que les jeunes disent
mal supporté ce sont les crs leur
patrouille leurs contrôles incessants
des crs venus d'autres villes et qui le
connaissent pas les habitants ils sont
là depuis plusieurs semaines pour
prévenir tout incident mais leur
présence fin décembre n'a pas empêché
une flambée de violence qui isole le
quartier l'exclu un peu plus qu'on ait
des jeunes dans les quartiers comme
samad appellent tous à bord en patron et
qui voit ce qui s'est passé dans le
quartier une semaine en rond et que toi
tu en auras pas trop que tu me dis que
j'habite ça tue ca c
c'est grillé on se grille on est grillé
si la délinquance baisse à toulouse
depuis cinq ans les institutions elles
sont de moins en moins respectée pendant
leur tournée
ces îlots qui essuient régulièrement des
insultes de la part des plus jeunes
souvent désoeuvrés et qu'il croise tous
les jours dans la rue
c'est pourquoi il ya des gens qui
brûlent des voitures pourquoi en 2010 à
celle utilisant ce qu'ils vont montrer
de mouches dans le quartier faire bouger
un peu l'activité est en train de
solliciter à l'école tu crois que ça
serait pas mieux que le cinéma ne pas
mais je dis que les joueurs c'est vrai
que les jours où tu iras l'école c'est
ça fait une belle activité de voir le
copain en vidéo puis vous applaudir sur
la ram ça s'est vu ce a déjà vu des
sourires entendus car la règle bien sûr
et de ne pas se faire prendre
alors que le jeu ne dérape à dire elle
est l'animateur a décidé lui de
président me défoncer pour les îles et
par toi et ce soir là avec les plans
sont faits qui avaient quelque chose à
nous demander si vous voyez le président
de la république est ce que vous verrez
pas les demandes et de notre parti pour
nous faire des terrains alors bagatelle
wafa roth
parce que on sait ce qu'il est capable
d'aller bloc déjà les accepte plus qu
est ce qu il leur manquerait cigana
durable et quand je dis du rêve c'est de
monter des projets des projets pour que
ces séries mais toulouse bouge oui mais
autrement
finalement il n'y aura pas eu recours
aux forces de l'ordre ont libéré normale
sup
cet ensemble de plein gré que la
quarantaine de chômeurs et d'étudiants a
quitté l'établissement
il est 18 heures en multipliant les
blocus les contrôles les arrestations
le gouvernement ne fait qu'attiser notre
colère aujourd'hui si nous sortons c'est
pour rejoindre l'assemblée générale qui
se tient juste yeux depuis 17h30
et pour continuer cette lutte multiforme
l'école était occupé depuis mercredi
soir repas tâches ménagères assemblée
générale que la vie s'était organisé à
l'intérieur du bâtiment
à l'extérieur le dispositif de sécurité
s'était fortement renforcée depuis les
incidents de samedi soir depuis nombre
d'autorités se sont fait entendre
le prix nobel de physique claude cohen
tannoudji souhaitée au plus vite un
retour à la normale même exigence du
directeur de l'école c'est une situation
qui perdure et qui empêche
l'établissement de fonctionner je ne
vois pas comment on va pouvoir garder
des gens éternellement attire
d'établissement
une assemblée générale se tient
actuellement la faculté de jussieu
étudiants et chômeurs vont décider les
nouvelles actions à mener
c'est l'une des grandes écoles de
commerce on entre à l'essec avec un
solide bagage de grandes ambitions et
quelques certitudes certitude de trouver
un bon job à la sortie par exemple voici
les catalogues d'offres de stages et
d'embûches
il déborde de propositions le chômage un
univers éloigné des préoccupations
personnelles des futurs cadres
supérieurs pensions nous et pourtant
c'est avec lucidité que les sup de co en
parle
arrivée plus ou moins tout le monde
avant un membre de sa famille se
retrouvent au chômage
pas du jour au lendemain mais pour une
durée brève ou plus ou moins longue
et c'est vrai que même si nous on a
beaucoup d'opportunités fin les gens
viennent nous proposer des stages des
emplois on sait très bien que ça durera
pas éternellement et que il se peut très
bien qu'un jour ou l'autre on se
retrouve dans la même situation
personnellement je pense que c'est pour
nous difficile d'être vraiment impliqué
avec les chômeurs parce qu'on est quand
même dans une situation assez
privilégiés man formation qui nous
permet de d'espérer avoir un emploi à la
sortie
et qu'en conséquence même si on peut
rester solidaires je pense que si je
disais ça un chômeur aujourd'hui je suis
solidaire je te soutiens
ça me ferais je pense rigoler on sort de
l'école on va essayer de trouver un
emploi mais effectivement non 5 ans 10
ans 15 ans
de riom autrefois ces étudiants signer
des contrats d'embauché avant même
d'avoir quitté l'école aujourd'hui les
emplois sont encore là mais la
probabilité de devoir affronter le
chômage un jour est loin d'être
inimaginable ils se sont plus musclé
plus plus équipés pour la bagarre que la
génération précédente qui l a vu arriver
le chômage comme un coup de matraque
ce n'est pas de la compassion que la
future élite des entreprises ressent à
l'égard des chômeurs mais plutôt même
chez ces jeunes là un début
d'identification déjà sous de gaulle
on parle de chômage dès la fin de 1958
le chef de l'état créé les assedic et
lunid autrement dit un fonds national
destiné au maintien à l'emploi et
assurant aux travailleurs qui tomberait
en chômage
un supplément portant l'allocation aux
environs du salaire minimum nous sommes
au coeur des trente glorieuses le pays
ne compte à l'époque que 25 mille
chômeurs en huit ans pourtant la
situation commence à se dégrader la
situation allait connu il ya
actuellement inscrits dans les bureaux
de madère 174 mille demandeurs d'emploi
je voudrais également précisé que le
nombre des demandeurs d'emploi dans tous
les grands pays industriels
un rapport naturellement à la population
active est sensiblement plus important
que la france le 13 juillet 67 est
construite la première anpe les demandes
d'emploi affluent la question du chômage
domine désormais le débat politique gage
ou cache pas qu'au travers des
difficultés du moment c'est le grand
problème qui me préoccupe pour la le cap
fatidique du million de chômeurs sera
franchie en 76
deux ans plus tôt était institué
l'allocation spéciale d'attentes qui
garantissait aux demandeurs d'emploi
100% de son dernier
bernet pendant un an déjà à cette époque
le gouvernement promet de faire de
l'emploi sa priorité
le gouvernement fera le nécessaire à
temps pour vous protéger du chômage il
en a la volonté et il en a les moyens
mais en 79 l'allocation spéciale
d'attenté supprimée elle coûte trop cher
à l'état
à son arrivée au pouvoir la gauche va
tenter de contenir la hausse du chômage
je vous ai dit quand 80 que fin 82 nous
serions 2010 aurions sur la crête des 2
millions de chômeurs nous y sommes
toujours en 82 l'état impose une baisse
des prestations et une hausse des
cotisations sous peine de faillite du
système en 84 le cap des deux millions
chômeurs est largement dépassé le
gouvernement instaure l'allocation
spécifique de solidarité pour les
chômeurs qui arrivent en fin de droits
mais dans le même temps la modernisation
de l'industrie provoque des
licenciements massifs et la colère des
salariés dans les mines la sidérurgie et
les constructions navales en 86 nouvelle
alternance nouvelles promesses
nouvelle déconvenue selon toute
vraisemblance les créations nettes
d'emplois ne suffiront pas ne seront
certainement pas à la hauteur de la
demande d'emploi alors sans surprise le
chômage et les exclus sont au coeur de
la campagne pour les présidentielles de
1988 la révolution française
après ses ennemis de luttes sociales
va-t-on laisser ces nouveaux ports comme
une ronde sous nos yeux et notre
incapacité à sauver et sauver les
consciences la même année et crée le rmi
une allocation d'état pour les plus
pauvres
mais rien n'y fait le cap des trois
millions de chômeurs est franchie nous
sommes en juin 93 l'unedic vient
d'imposer la location unique dégressive
désormais quand on est demandeur
d'emploi plus le temps passe moins on
est indemnisé
vous avez ya rien de nouveau
robert hue il était contre l'euro avant
même les élections il participe à
travers des ministres communistes dans
un gouvernement qui prépare l'euro avec
des conditions alors c'est à lui que se
pose la question nous ne changerons pas
de cas nous irons vers l'euro avec des
conditions qui sont protectrices pour la
croissance économique et pôle emploi
et puis dans une certaine mesure il faut
absolument que le cap soit préservé
parce que sinon on n'y comprend rien et
donc aux communistes de comprendre
aujourd'hui ils ont sans doute des
fidélités à respecter par rapport à
leurs discours d'il ya quelques mois
mais aussi une solidarité respecter
parce que nous gagnerons ensemble nous
perdons ensemble comme un étudiant à
quelques minutes du grand oral
l'universitaire michel bergès révise par
voie de presse michel bergès a souvent
critiqué l'instruction et ce procès
aujourd'hui il se fait plus discret il
rentre au palais par une porte dérobée
celle qu'empruntent chaque jour maurice
papon tout un symbole il ya 15 ans
michel bergès était aux côtés des
victimes
aujourd'hui il a changé de camp pendant
deux heures l'homme essaye de justifier
ce revirement
une lecture différente du dossier dit-il
ce sont les allemands les auteurs du
crime
la préfecture a essayé de faire
contrepoids mais michel bergès reste
prudent très en retrait pour le
sauvetage des juifs dit il il y a eu des
interventions mais c'était du
grappillage et michel bergès reconnaît
qu'il est difficile pour lui d' analyser
les documents
plusieurs fois il utilise le
conditionnel michel slitinsky son ancien
ami note durement le professeur agrégé
il s'apparente à un témoignage du coc
moyenne deuxième année il est clair que
c'est un non événement ça ne modifie pas
le cours du procès l'instruction à
l'audience était infiniment plus riche
dans les dernières semaines
pétard mouillé aujourd'hui on vient nous
annoncer à grand renfort de presse
monsieur michel bergès et le témoin clé
de l'accusation il bien qu'est ce qu'il
nous dit à rien trois fois rien d'un
conte ce peuple le soufflé retomber très
vite la défense aussi se réjouit car
elle note que michel bergès n'a citée
qu'une fois maurice papon
c'est la compréhension par un véritable
historien qui connaît ce qui s'est passé
qui connaît le dossier comme personne
c'est une analyse dont vous avez
remarqué que maurice papon est
pratiquement absent cela devait être un
cours d'histoire il faut simplement
parler de l'intimé conviction de michel
bergès pas de certitude que des
hypothèses de travail et ce soir c'est
un juré qu'à poser la question la plus
percutante aux témoins pensez vous que
vous allez encore changer d'avis pour
moi répondu michel bergès l'enquète
continue
une institutrice jean feignent depuis
neuf ans et je gagne net à 8300 francs
aux environs du métro à 100 francs
alors je suis professeur des écoles
j'exerce depuis trois ans et je gagne
actuellement un salaire de 1700 francs
nets instituteurs professeurs des écoles
de nom de statuts différents pour une
même profession recrutés après la
réforme de 89
selanne a été formé comme les
professeurs des collèges des lycées
il est payé comme eux c'était pas le
classer en zone sensible de la banlieue
parisienne
il est confronté aux mêmes difficultés
ce ses collègues d'instituteur pour
constater quelques fois non pas un
manque de respect mais une vision une
façon de parler quelques fois agressif
parce que vive la violence au quotidien
laurence enseigne dans la même école et
depuis plus longtemps que stéphane elle
est pourtant moins payés recruter avant
la création du corps des professeurs des
écoles
elle a été formée moins longtemps je
trouve que c'est pas très normal qu'au
sein d'un même métier métier difficile
de surcroît les enseignants et de
statuts différents donc voir de paye
c'est vrai que c'est difficile de se
motiver en sachant qu'on gagne moins que
le copain d'à côté
nous oui alors c'est sûrement en faisant
il y aurait eu derrière que donner la
parole au lendemain par solidarité sdefa
nous aurons grève comme laurence afin de
gommer ces disparités salariales pour
que les aînés ne soit plus jaloux de
leurs cadets lionla chrome échelle cela
ressemble à roméo et juliette
elle est à son balcon il est au
téléphone mais cela reste une histoire
d'amour contrariée discuté avec mon
épouse parce qu'on voulait savoir
comment on faisait pour les enfants ce
soir et puis moi même rentrer et puis et
puis aulas a débloqué à la maison depuis
depuis ce matin là regardez là bas le
chemin d'accès et transformé en temps
entourant la ma propriété bon et
inaccessible de ce côté là voilà ce soir
ce monsieur dormir à shenzhen un mètre
d'eau dans certaines rues de figeac et
c'est tout un quartier celui de londieu
qui s'est laissé surprendre le cd qui
traverse la ville a dépassé de près de
deux mètres sa cote d' alerte les
pompiers ont évacué deux personnes mais
plusieurs particuliers ont préféré
rester chez eux
c'est le cas dans ce hameau quelques
kilomètres en aval ils sont les gens qui
donnent dans leur maison ils ont pu
sortir par de repartir pour dire
attendre de sortir car ici on est
habitués aux caprices du célé cet après
midi tout de même la direction de
l'équipement a jugé vous de lester ce
pont à figeac au moyen de ses deux
camions chargés de sable dans une
situation extrême effectivement le pont
pour éventuellement est amené à se
soulever et auquel cas et être emportée
et c'est pour prévenir cette ce risque
que nous avons installé une charge qui
doit le maintenir dans ce dans son point
d'appui
cette nuit d'autres précipitations sont
prévues un peu plus loin à cahors le lot
vient lui aussi de dépasser sa cote d'
alerte
quinze mois il trente mille heures de
travail pour passer d'une maquette à ce
prototype grandeur nature de tgv
pendulaires articulé présenté
aujourd'hui en grandes pompes ce
démonstrateur pendulaires s'incline
progressivement dans les virages comme
une moto
objectif gagner de la vitesse tout en
assurant un meilleur niveau de confort
pour les voyageurs
c'est un tgv qui a une gamme de
d'aptitude qui est plus élevé que le tgv
actuelles les 300 km heure sur lignes
nouvelles
il va continuer à pouvoir les assurés en
supplément sur des parcours terminaux il
pourra rouler plus vite qu'un cannes tgt
classique grâce justement à la porte de
la population ce démonstrateur est donc
un objet unique au monde qui allie les
avantages des trains pendulaires et les
qualités de nos tgv classique
c'est-à-dire vitesse et sécurité dus à
nos rames articulées le tgv n'est pas
d'un prêt ordinaire c'est un trafic eut
les cires un train ou les des voitures
sont très liés entre eux ce qui rend
beaucoup plus difficile le problème de
la population c'est un problème auquel
on s'est attaqué avec la sncf et on
pense qu'on est venu à bout puisque vous
avez pu voir que le train pendule vous
l'avez eue bouger et le 1er avril comme
premier roulera et ponts du rhin si les
essais s'avèrent concluants la sncf
élargira sa gamme de trains à grande
vitesse avec le tgv pendulaires la
construction de nouvelles lignes
deviendra peut-être superflu en cette
fin d'après midi de ramadhan les
algérois se prépare à la rupture du
jeûne
la sortie des bureaux pendant que
beaucoup de femmes préparent la chorba
la soupe
les hommes eux achètent des friandises
et du pain mais ce 21e jour de ramadhan
est à marquer d'une pierre blanche pour
la première fois une délégation de
secrétaire d'état de la troïka
européenne arrive à alger le terrorisme
restait quelques minutes une autre usine
ici on est clair puisque les européens
arrivent maintenant est reparti de me
convertir en fer en 24 heures c'est un
petit pont voyez ça nous permet de faire
dans cette situation les jo
hassan pourtant est sensible à la
démarche européenne
en fait quand on à la police dans le
derrière pour ne pas les algériens parce
qu'on pense que ya quand même des gens
qui prend une femme à quelques centaines
de mètres sur les hauteurs d'alger le
quartier de vous arrive
c'est ici que samedi soir encore d'après
le journal le matin
un groupe armé a tiré sur des habitants
sans l'intervention des forces de
sécurité
c'aurait été le massacre a ici tu es la
rupture du jeûne en amidon et les
habitants vivent dans la peur des
terroristes qui peut se cacher à deux
pas ils seront peut-être nulle part et
partout
mais l'algérie continue de vivre avec du
courage pour chaque jour avec un islam
attaché surtout à la paix et à ses
traditions
non c'est tout
en sueur carmina ne marche pas dans son
jardin mais dans son église laissé à
l'abandon depuis le triomphe de la
révolution cubaine en 1959 cette
religieuse ne porte pas le voile cubaine
de coeur et missionnaire les venues
d'espagne voilà vingt ans pour
transmettre sa foi
elle a dû se battre contre la
discrimination et le manque de moyens de
l'église pour fidel castro un bon
communiste est actée et la nationaliser
toutes les écoles et la volée il n'a pas
volu on enchaînait les points de déficit
en lice mais n'est ce pas alors les
églises en entier beaucoup de
difficultés au commencement
mais quand même ici il n'ya pas j'ai une
persécution ventures
on ne peut pas nous chasser c'est pas
vrai aucune goutte de son ecclésiastique
n'a été versée mais les églises se sont
vidés et la peur s'est installé pendant
30 ans aujourd'hui le prêtre n'officie
plus dans cette église mais les
paroissiens se réunissent pour préparer
la visite du pape
ces petits drapeaux cubains les fidèles
les brandir haut pour saluer le
saint-père dire qu'il y a eu récemment
une ouverture de la faim durant sa
lumière par rapport à la religion
et peut-on dire aujourd'hui qu'on est
communiste et catholique puis
le regard bienveillant de jean paul ii
les jeunes cubains suivent leur tout
premier cours de catéchisme karina qui
donne également des cours de philosophie
au séminaire adapte ici son discours
elle leur explique simplement ce qu'elle
d'athènes ou bien qui est le pape
bavarois pointent la venue du pape peut
faire changer les choses nous aider à
sortir de cette crise économique
moi j'ai la foi d'un incroyant le rêve
de diego c'est celui de beaucoup de
cubains catholique ou pas du pape nous
attendent un appel à la levée de
l'embargo américain
il espère surtout que celui qui a su
ébranlé le colosse soviétique favorisera
une ouverture du régime castriste
en attendant la restauration de l'église
du rosario
c'est dans un bagage ou que les nouveaux
fidèles se pressent librement à la messe
sainte hermine à la visite du pape et
déjà s'ils ont une plus grande influence
le rythme du tango aussi lancinant et
entêtant que l'odeur des rousses faste
de l'opéra détail canada n'y regarde
star amitié et personnalités
et c'est la haute couture comme un
spectacle dior le revendique haut et
fort et john galliano rien n'est trop
beau
ce créateur étant d'emblée considéré
thomas j tout est permis
dans le temps il s'est inspiré de barney
amusé à gaza qui pour lancer salut ou
locus la collection et dans un hommage à
cette marque italienne excentrique du
début du siècle a mis des pinceaux de
poètes les mannequins portent comme
albert pons attaque sous les bretelles
bijoux t pour des bals du sien
et l'arrêté
juste la mairie
tiens force c'est une brillante
démonstration de professionnels
de longuenesse près de fleurs
par les temps qui courent on a aussi
besoin de voter furent deux matches
depuis
on a même vu certaines femmes remplir
leurs carnets de commandes
entre une coupe de champagne qu'une
bouchée de magasins
ce n'est pas sardou qui habite merci les
persie qui habite sartoux au delà de
l'institution
pas de veine institut jeunes assidus
science et vous vous avez que ça un
monument
elle est un monument que ça sera mieux
voilà on va du bourg autour de la scène
avant j'étais au monument fixe mon chien
un monument mobiles l'idée bouger des
quatre coins de la scène
face aux quatre coins de la salle
voyage bouger c'est une nouveauté pour
michel sardou
il s'est lancé ce défi il a tout conçu
il veille à tous et surtout il faut
attendre que les musiciens vous
attendrez un petit peu dans la fosse
les gens commencent à dégager et là vous
sortez vous une chanson quelques
nouveautés c'est là dans ce fauteuil son
spectateur religieux comme un père
débordant d'orgueil
je lui prends la soute ou m'appelez plus
jamais
la france mais avantage d'être
absolument c'est pour le connais même
quand on ne connaît pas peur
à
rabat landais
baticle vous avez jamais vus sur 7 0 se
connaît de nouvelles chansons par coeur
il n'avait jamais vu c'est étonnant vous
êtes populaire mais pas populiste
non non c'est très différent peu plus la
reprise ne pas dire la même chose
c'est très différent populaire c'est
très difficile
populis c'est très facile est-ce que
vous avez encore quelque chose à ajouter
après sa non sinon c'est pas toujours
compris
que cela vous surprennent dont tant pis
un moment que nous avons le sont pas
seulement les chansons c'est quand
le spectacle est fini
m
salué la chanson qui clôt le spectacle
chansons en forme de pop reggae
l'autocritique ou quand ça remonte
explique sa mère
menu maupas
bah